when i go to a nice hotel you take a
bath i bring bath bombs
unreal
back off my broccolini
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
i gotta tell you it was it's all it was
all blur
the themes well the thing because i
wrote some things on an index card of
what i wanted to do got up there and in
my mind i swear to god my mind went
blank did you go over the set in the
mirror at home before yeah dude i did
all that i was like
yeah i did the whole thing in my my room
um but you know what's weird i realized
there's like a psychology going on
in the room like where i before you go
on yeah i felt like they know
if you're like desperate like they could
sense [ __ ] oh yeah you're a lion tamer
yeah i'm just like you know like because
i could like the things i thought okay
this is gonna work didn't work there's
only one way to find out but the things
that i didn't even plan or
whatever just saying worked worked yeah
so i don't know what what's going on
there let me say now
okay let me say now from a professional
yeah yeah yeah yeah i want to say that i
was really proud of you
how you went up there you didn't get you
weren't nervous even if you weren't
nervous you didn't show it dude i was so
nervous okay but you should be you
didn't i was trembling i was like oh i
was scared i was like oh well listen
listen he didn't show it he was he he
commanded the stage you were very
comfortable talking to people he was
interacting with people it was like a
whole thing
i feel like
i felt like that if if i wasn't standing
there kind of being like all right he
would have kept going yeah you know what
i mean yeah and so it was a great
comeback uh you know and he did have
some jokes i i recorded it but he didn't
want me to show it to you guys let's not
show that down though let me let me go
through
it yeah
when i have a good five minutes in
record that yeah but he was like okay
again it was like very comfortable and
he you did it and it was great and i'm
glad you got that out of the way and now
you're going to just have to get out
there and keep doing it because that's
99 of people couldn't even just get on
stage a little louder i don't know how
the hell you guys do amphitheater i
don't know how the hell you guys do
these shows without do you guys still
get scared
nervous for sure i don't know i do i've
been doing long enough though no but
this guy he could have taken a nap up
there he was like leaning against this
mic
i only get nervous when it depends on
like like let's say you're you know
you're doing some you know stadium show
or whatever it is you're doing some show
where somebody's like like i did a show
with dane cook one time and it was like
so many people within the day it was no
no this was recently yeah like he was on
this tour before covet and it was like
we were in like austin or something and
the place was like three thousand people
you know nothing i don't care
but if i'm in like a hick bar someplace
yeah and there's six people in there
where they're gonna just no no no no but
somebody says
hey spielberg's filming a movie and he's
out there because they're filming a
movie down the street and he's in the
crowd
that would make me nervous
so what i'm saying is
it it depends on the stakes like like
you know and even if they're
manufactured in your head it don't
matter how many people or nothing like
that it don't matter if i can perform
any time i don't care the only thing
that makes what makes you nervous is
like when you're like auditioning or
yeah i got nervous you know when i was
in brainerd because my family has let me
do this hasn't seen me do you stand like
see that kind of stuff that's what i'm
saying and then my girl my mother-in-law
the our close friends or yeah and they
sat him in the front room like wow oh i
hate that but even the manager cameron
was like dude we're sorry man someone
[ __ ] up yeah
they sat your whole family in the front
room
how do you mentally prepare for that you
just got power through it yeah you're
proud and then and then my whole bid is
on being married to mexican i go hard in
the paint on them and they haven't seen
the set i was like oh no but they're
having a good time yeah so when does it
when you guys get more comfortable like
doing your doing it oh you always get
better yeah yeah yeah so that never goes
away that never goes away so that's good
to know though because when i went to
like your guys shows theo shows or
whatever i've been like should i sit up
front and i'm like i'm like not because
i yeah but then i'm like is it
narcissism that i think he'd even
[ __ ] notice me because like no he
will yeah so the first thing i made the
right choice yeah yeah you don't want to
sit yeah i hate seeing people right know
you know one time i i was doing you know
my parents have an oxnard you know
and you know say my mom's got dementia
and so
i i'm doing a show they actually like
live really close by that improv the
levity yeah and so i you know i told my
stepfather are you going to bring her i
need to know
because i do jokes about this
you know what i mean she's not going to
remember i know but i have a whole thing
about it and then you know luckily this
one particular show i didn't do it i
come out and there they are
you know i was so mad at my stepfather i
was like what are you doing man i got a
whole thing about this you just you know
they don't know though like like my mom
when i perform in denver she's like we
want front row i'm like nope please mom
yeah yeah yeah blend in right
yeah but it's like you know that's what
i'm saying so so for steve you know it's
gonna be fine but i think that a lot of
the
you doing a podcast for so long what
you've been doing with jeremiah now yeah
yeah it's like performing i know it
helps but they're surrounded but there's
a difference though i noticed that like
when i do this i don't know when i'm
being funny i just i'm just you know i'm
just talking to you guys but i noticed
last night i was hyper aware of [ __ ]
one in like it was like last night it
was a sunday show
i was aware of all that and i was in my
head i'm like oh no but this is why the
silences too
i didn't like that like when i thought i
was going to get a lot out of silence
you got to be here and there was silent
i would start freaking out inside of you
oh no it's not working yeah now steve
you have to well i told you last night
man is i want you to recognize once you
recognize why you're funny if you know
the things that make people laugh about
you physically
emotionally whatever that makes you
laugh wakes makes people laugh about you
once you can recognize it you could
control it and then now you could
make your set like that that's
interesting can i also throw this in
there
is there something where you kind of
have to make it seem like it's on the
fly like natural like the way you're
delivering your jokes you know what
there's no right or wrong way because
there are there are some people who are
wordsmiths like uh seinfeld he's
constructing a word play word jokes in a
way and people know yeah and they're
laughing because they are acknowledging
the way you put that sentence together
is funny and then there's other people
who are conversational no what's my
brother let's use conversational um yeah
he does a lot of act outs wouldn't you
say yeah but that's the difference he's
an actor physically yeah he's a physical
guy yeah he's physical but he's also
he's also presenting it as like these
are jokes stories you know you know what
i mean but he knows it works he's been
doing for so long brandon he knows that
stuff works my first set uh first
straight up stand-up spot was at the
comedy store in the belly room that was
your first spot first spot ever but in
the crowd is
brian callan
rogan crystalia will sasso my agents
from ca like that was just a nightmare
oh that was heavy hitters yeah i was
like bro you guys don't need to come to
this like this isn't that sounds like an
actual nightmare dude
it was a nightmare nightmare
nightmare i mean it's like like i say
when you when steaks are on the line
it's all about your mental like i
remember
when i'm at the comedy store one night
it's a tuesday night
and
atomy get you know he comes up to me
who's that he's the manager the man he
used to be the manager yeah i remember
him
he's rogan's book yeah adam says to me
he goes hey eric jim carrey's here
what that would have made me nervous no
that no no let me let me that's not what
happened word my first question to him
was is he bumping me you know that was
my first question and then i was mad i
was like what the hell is jim carrey
doing here at you know he got 300
million dollars in the bank he coming
here on a tuesday to bump people i was
just so i was so worked up about it you
know that i went on stage and i uh you
know i had a great set yeah but what i
didn't know is it was jim carrey and all
the producers of i'm dying up here oh
the documentary you get this roll up
based off that set i got to audition
because of that set and i was on the
show three weeks later and you crushed
it on no now what i'm saying is this
what i'm saying is this though if i had
known that i may not have had a headset
like like that anger i had about like
you know
he hasn't been here
yeah you know you know i was so like it
was you know you know it's another thing
another time that happened to me too is
like again
you know i'm about to go into
maintenance i'm about to go in the main
room and adam
he says he goes hey man
do your a stuff
okay that's what he says now why do you
think he says like don't try because he
knows like showtime's their netflix or
something that's interesting that you
went to that first that's what i would
think okay no no wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait juan i would say i
saw my let's say adam said that to me in
my head i'm thinking all right
showtime's there comedy central or
netflix or
after me is chappelle or wrote or some
big boy see that's great you have a very
this is a this says something by you
right now and what it says about you is
that you have a positive outlook on life
oh yeah okay yeah and and i learned a
lesson
with this because my first instinct was
like
you don't tell me do my a stuff
yeah that's right [ __ ] i always do you
know man
all right
so i'm in the green room pasting and i'm
like
get the [ __ ] out of here it was so in my
head go out and i i did do i i did like
i was like okay i'll pick a g you know
that was crushing you know what i'm
saying and then he comes up to me later
he goes go he goes man ted was out there
who's ted that's what i said so then i
got battered so then i got bags i'm like
who's ted ted dances here
yeah oh no but it was ted serranos from
netflix there you go you know what i
mean oh yeah adam's are you all right
you know what i mean that's right
and so after that i started to go you
know what i got to stop
i got to stop being so negative being so
negative yeah yeah i really did i was
like i need to stop being so negative i
need to like you know not everything is
you know not everybody's out there
right right but but but see i used that
energy a lot in the beginning of my
career to overcome you know if i was a
chip on your shoulder yeah and somebody
told me i was always like this even when
i was in high school when i was i was
playing basketball to get on the team it
was like you know the coach was like
getting on my case like you're not good
and i was like oh i'm not good yeah and
then i went to basketball camp man like
i'll never forget i went to basketball
camp and then like i remember so now
we're late in the middle of the season
and like at the time you got your name
in the paper if you scored 20 points in
high school if you scored 20 points so i
remember like i scored 20 points in the
game three games in a row and so i
remember this the coach who had like was
bad mouthing me right he's going down
the line and he's like all right the
next team we're playing you know they're
gonna be ready for us they know that and
he went to my one buddy harold he's like
you know harold's this he went to the
next guy and then he went to me
and he had he paused for a second
because i was looking at him like this
you read the paper [ __ ] that was like
in my mind i was like yeah you go ahead
and say it say it i could have quit
after that say it because he was saying
and eric and when he said that it was i
could have just went like this thank you
i'm out i'm out of here drop the mic
my daily routine
right now consists of yoga
uh two days a week i'm going to the ufc
gym rsc mma gym sorry
and then
uh outside of that i'm doing a lot of
prayer and
so i'm doing the inside workout
but
i sweat
i do i don't like to admit it i like to
hide it i'll even put baby powder all
over my body
but if you work out yoga whatever
whatever you do
you need to stay hydrated if you fly a
lot or if you walk down the street and
get chapped lips all of that liquid iv
can help
first thing in the morning before a
workout after a workout when you feel
run down you're about to fight with your
girl liquid iv you're going to beat one
of your children
don't do it on a dehydrated vibe
daily hydration maintenance hangover
cure etc liquid iv
they have lemon lime strawberry
watermelon
and immune support in tangerine they
have it all contains five essential
vitamins more vitamin c than an orange
and as much potassium as a banana damn
fruit attack
grab your favorite liquid iv flavors
nationwide at walmart you can get 25 off
when you go to liquidive.com and use
code kats at checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you get better
hydration today using promo code kats at
liquid iv.com
look the holidays are here if you don't
believe it look at a damn calendar you
jerk
look at a calendar
huh
dude i'm gonna love this year when
they're doing they're jingling for the
change thing outside of the walmart or
whatever and there's a chain shortage
so people are gonna be like what
why are you out here
but i mean you can't eat well hello
fresh
the holidays can be hectic hello fresh
keeps things simple with recipes and
ingredients that cut out grocery
shopping and limit meal prep time so you
can spend more time more the festive
season with friends and family
they offer 50 menu and market items to
choose from
every week wow it's a lot
i think it's a lot including vegetarian
vegetarian
calorie smart and gourmet options
provide plenty of variety
hello fresh is a can't beat value even
at full price
even at full price it's over 30 cheaper
than grocery stores jeeps
and with this holiday deal it's time to
try
and save that money
yep how does it save you time around the
holidays well you know what you're going
to make it's easy get the kids involved
it's fun it's festive go to
hellofresh.com
1 4 k ing
use code 1 4 k ing for up to 14 free
meals and three free gifts it's the
holiday time you get a gift
yep
that's it they also have a green chef
partnership if you worked with green
chef in the past or are currently you
must address the hello fresh green chef
relationship that's right go to
hellofresh.com14king14k ing use code 14
king for up to 14 free mails
free meals and three free gifts i've
used hellofresh i love it i used to do
it with my nieces and we would cook and
make a plan i would do with a date an of
age date so a lot of options there
treat the ones you love with
eats hello fresh
to be like i had a huge chip on my
shoulder when i first started podcast
remember i was like in the in a battle
with dana white and dude when i say a
chip i had a [ __ ] box of pringles on
my shoulder but that fire is what got me
through all of it yeah and now i'm on
the other end i'm like whoa my batman
it's all good so are you guys saying you
need that chip on your shoulder a little
bit
there has to be something there it can't
be everybody's trying to [ __ ] you over
like my thing at the economy story like
i'm just lucky to be there right like
i'm just surrounded by greatness so
whatever so i was supposed to do a spot
and uh me and jim gaffkin would uh dm
each other back and forth and we've
never met in person and then uh i think
adam or emily came up to me like hey i
know you're looking forward to this but
uh somebody's gonna bump you man so
you're going later and i was like cool
all good and so i'm standing just while
i'm like man though i wonder who the
[ __ ] pumping me has to be somebody
good and then jim gaffkin comes behind
me goes hello instagram
he friends i hate to do it to you man
buddy another spot at the improv dude do
your thing man do you think that's
interesting how does that work at the
comedy store could they just so the
pop-ins they have the they have a
building
nobody likes it if no no but it happens
all the time doesn't it not necessarily
all the time
didn't carlos yeah but that turned into
a big thing you know
to me it's like at the comedy store you
could call you could call in and get
your spot no matter what you want but i
also kind of get it because i think jim
was there he was doing a set at the uh
in the main room and then he was like
man i want to run this new joke in the
belly room can i go up there before i do
the main room like yeah for sure like
who's on like
job
he's just like you to be here you know
what i'm saying no but you know what
they see okay i'm in a different feeling
about it sometimes though like when a
big person like that comes and says to
you like hey man can i go now because i
got to get to another spot well you're a
big guy
you don't need to get to that other spot
because when you get there you can go up
when you want true so don't tell me
about my thing don't tell me you're
doing this to get to another spot yeah
you just don't want to wait yeah like my
[ __ ] is like just own that yeah
okay you know what i mean just own it
like don't be telling me you know i
gotta get like as if at the other place
they're gonna be like well you have to
go up at this time no you're drew carey
did that to me at uh the laugh factory
but you've been doing it for how many
years you know 20 years how long have
you been like can you imagine if jim was
like you might have to go i'm like nah
duh yeah you're gonna hold
that's why you're mad about it because
you know you have no say no well you
can't do that you can't stand up for
yourself
that's like what's the point but i also
feel like like jim gaffigan drew carrick
they've yeah they've earned it right but
that's what my point is that you've
earned it so don't give me the [ __ ]
yeah i know just because i got to get to
another spot i'm not trying to get home
too late if i don't wait
like i want to go up now yeah okay yeah
yeah you respect that more yes because
he's
uh okay
so how long do they usually go up like
40 minutes 30 minutes no no no no no no
i've had some big comics go on bump me
and go on even when i was headlining at
the store
ice house i won't say their name i've
had big comics go on and do
90 minutes no
60 90 minutes so what happens then do
you just leave no hell no so yeah for 90
all right well that's the way you do it
i guess you know you got to be political
this is where i'm at schmuck
uh no
no he wouldn't do that dane's never
that's the thing so like
all my friends who i [ __ ] with who are
big in these common spaces
they all came up in those days when dane
cook you know i guess was a little bit
toxic
my thing is my interactions with dane
have always been f he's always been so
supportive man i only said on this past
weekend him and theo had a big
discussion about that's why back in the
day he was not well liked because he
would do that he would do it for hours
but doesn't do it to me
same to me he's only been really nice
but listen i'll say who it is like the
guy who did it to me it was my first
time ever headlining the comedy store
and they called me on a day's notice i
was like [ __ ] say let's tell you i'll be
right there headline the belly room [ __ ]
yeah first time i met so i'm like man
wonder why they called me out all the
guys and what are they calling me so
then my girl's like it's game seven of
the dodgers in the world series ain't
nobody's showing up like oh [ __ ]
there's seven people there i'm like i'm
such a loser
and i'm waiting in the back and then
dave chappelle walks in he says hey man
i heard you're you're you mind if i go
like do your thing dog dude he performed
for 60 minutes for those seven people
like he did math square garden yeah yeah
then i had to follow that you got to
follow jesus
okay you know but he's usually pretty
good about that too no he was good he
was like he was like you do you want me
to go before i was like
dude
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do do your
thing and then i can go before you after
i don't care he's like well i'll go i'll
just go then i'm gonna do your thing man
well yeah yeah cause you easily could
have said i like how about you could
have been like could i give you an
example i have a story like this too is
remember
john lovitz oh yeah club you know a
crazy name for our you know comedy club
you know what i mean but anyways one
night i was covering for someone else
they had a show and so they wanted me to
close the show right so i'm like all
right i'll close the show like i'm there
doing mencia walks in you know and he's
like it was at the universal city walk
it's the height of muncie no no no no
this was like the town to thailand but
you know he's still mencia he still
sells well that's not impressive so he
was like so he comes up he goes you know
he comes up to me and he's like i say to
him
i'll just go up and do 20 and then you
could close out the show and do whatever
you want to be better he's like well you
know i got to get to a movie
i got to go through yeah i got to go to
a movie and uh you know and hey man just
come get me just get me off stage oh
yeah you want me to come up and get you
yeah
yeah i mean what are you talking about
yeah of course he goes on and does
whatever time [ __ ] up there's no movie
he's going to because he's still there
oh so he's lied to you
i'm just like dude i i would have done
i would have conceded the time to you
just do that you know what i mean like
and it would have been better for
everybody it would have been better for
everybody what is it of why can't they
just be honest what is up with this
passive aggression
like carlos some like you know we'll do
similar venues like dude carlos was here
last week and he did four hours man yeah
yeah like an hour two people you know
walking out and he just powers through
it and the worst part is he did eric set
yeah yeah you know
though you know i like here's an example
of somebody that it knows exactly the
situation so i was at i forgot i think
it was in burbank
and
damon wayans he's funny dude baby comes
and he goes when you going up and i said
uh i think i'm going next he goes i'm
gonna bump you you know and i was like i
was like man you're a bastard you know
but
that's real yeah
why don't you do this it's like no like
it's like you know what
if you think you a big dog be a big dog
yeah deal that card pull the card and do
it don't [ __ ] around it yeah yeah don't
be a [ __ ] about it i'd much rather be
yeah then be like hey man i'm going on
next you know what i'm saying because
that's what i want to do and i'm also
[ __ ] bow down
right so exactly you've been doing
comedy for two minutes when you want
i've been looking for going 30 years you
know i'm next like you do that thing
like yeah i want to go next you're
nothing like hulk hogan yeah
how would you guys deal with that when
you guys get to the top
would you be honest and be like hey i'm
bumping i don't think i've ever been i
don't think i'd bump into it
huh i don't think i'd bump anybody
because then like
my bo my close friend got bumped the
other weekend and it went around town
like you hear who bum bums right right
right
word spreads oh yeah wildfire
what a [ __ ] you know people don't like
that guy no comics hate that even bill
burr would be like stop putting me a
special guest yeah he just wants to be
on the line yeah he's a real one yeah
you know what i mean because he knows
how that is
we got some good uh king at her stinger
some good debate clubs this guy's got a
king interesting at that or a debate
club that's a little halloween recap
related
and then actually we've got a uh
surprise guest later to kind of solidify
our new crew i won't say more on that
there's a guest coming in here yeah
in person yeah
who's gonna sit here a famous white
rapper
[Laughter]
oh i know it's a tom hanks son
that'd be sick [ __ ] chet hanks
it's not chad oh cause i'm an island boy
those guys are in trouble
for hitting his girl oh yeah okay he
must have sucked her in the mouth and
then she's just whooping his ass and she
posts the video she's like look at my
mouth she has this dread stuff
and he's like
yeah it's great
she beat the [ __ ] out but they got a
record deal right the island boys i
don't i don't care i don't know i don't
know i mean that was a hit wasn't it is
eminem here that'd be great
look at my [ __ ] mouth you want to be
like your [ __ ] father
she's on the one drive that's not island
boy is it that's him no he goes you want
to be like your father
was he crying like this though he's so
violent
she is so violent and she's beating his
ass
she beat the [ __ ] out of them no there's
probably girls out there like oh my god
i'll take care of you yeah girl you
don't yeah
island boy you don't need to deal with
that toxic relationship
well
it's all [ __ ] small
you know she was whooping his ass yeah
yeah yeah he must have just like got one
on her she's like oh hell no like what
why'd he cry like that though like who's
the who's the uh abuser in this
situation like you're looking at this
like i can't believe he did that to her
well she's
all right so this guy's got a debate
club for us what's up king this thing
how we doing brendan theo stevie eric
i've got a debate question for you all
uh what is the best costume you saw this
holiday a set of lips on them saw
someone reenact that uh carol baskin
husband wedding photo um had the leash
and everything a little too kinky for my
liking but uh what are your thoughts
go ahead guys my my brother-in-law came
as uh the [ __ ] tiger king and carol
baskin it was spot on although he looked
like a tijuana uh oh wow
that's the actual character
yeah and she killed him so that's cool
yeah she murdered him dude bass costume
was my son boston he was baby yoda and
he shut the [ __ ] [ __ ] let me check it
out he was so goddamn cute it shut the
street down oh zoom in on me
you guys did a star wars theme there you
go
i like that are you a big star wars guy
brandon not at all i had no saying this
my girl's like here you're [ __ ] up
obi-wan kenobi i'm like
you know
that's another thing my ewok joke didn't
work what's the work joke okay let's go
on to the next
one to the next um
i thought steve's costume was uh
you know what i'm not giving you any
credit for the costumes
because yeah that's rich people costumes
like that's the actual darth vader thing
you have like y'all went out and spent
money on that you don't get credit for
that that's fair i can't stand that's
fair i can't stand rich people costumes
when they like you know freddy krueger
they have the actual freddy cougar
things they got like obviously
prosthetics
bro you came in here as [ __ ] king
henry the third that was that she bought
that at the party city that's where this
shake them dollars go get them go you
think that you think that suit came with
those tits and ass for darth vader this
is like that's real daddy man this is
like that's like three hundred dollars
right yeah at least
that's a lot of money for our customers
to be honest where'd you get the stuff
where did you buy the my girl got it off
amazon yeah
amazon i want to see that bill obi-wan
kenobi they might have got the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
500.
it's not i'm saying this is it's nice
when people do that but i saw this from
the nba the nba on the nba instagram
they had like all the nba players and i
was like mine was like the incredible i
was like look at these
rich [ __ ] with their like you
know everybody had makeup on and all
this stuff it was like legit like movie
costumes
i don't give credit for that yeah you're
a hater
i know who did the most savage costume
and i have no opinion on it but the the
dude from uh fox news did that alex
baldwin with the gun from the set up
yeah
did the gun he's taken so much [ __ ] for
it yeah my opinion is that so people
always try to be that edgy person too
soon too much too much too soon and i'm
i'm actually throwing stones in glass
house because one year i was uh
chocolate face crocodile hunter uh it
was it was four days after he died oh i
like that you had that you had the
heading i i had a very i had this thing
right now but i like when people are the
son of a [ __ ]
linda lived and learned yeah that that
might be worse than alex ball but at
least al baldwin's still alive like i
like when people do costumes like
like let's say
let's say like
you know you want to do like the king
and i
so like
like if my girl is dressed as a king and
i'm dressed as an eye
that'd be cool you know i like those
type of colors oh that's creative that's
why
it took yeah you know you know
yeah that's right well it wasn't it was
a poor person's costume that's why but
it's still you oh there's still the face
paint made it
gang gang buzz buzz damn that's pretty
spot on well that is kind of spot on
it's like theo if you got plastic
surgery
yeah that's pretty spot on
this was one that was going around uh
there was a party in mar-a-lago
and uh
someone she'd that's funny instead of
aoc's tax the rich she can marry the
risk
that's a white person's costume there
uh i had a couple more good ones from
some of our listeners that he sent
theirs in there's
bob ross oh i like that's great yeah
bob
ross thick
robin hood yeah and the guy in the
middle is just a guy
yeah all right okay maybe he's the
makeup artist maybe probably the best
island boy costume that was floating
around the internet
even though we just oh you know who had
a legit [ __ ] costume crystalia what
was he he was from oh yeah
holy moly oh [ __ ] and warrior i know
this guy he's really funny dude
are they singing
[Laughter]
that's great man chris is [ __ ] good
what was he he was uh from rick and
morty oh
pretty [ __ ] good oh nice see rich
people costume
is homophobic because he killed two
gay
uh
a gay couple in the movie the problem
with michael myers isn't that he's
homophobic you know he's a murderer the
problem with michael myers is that he's
a psychopath killer
still
he's not real
michael myers has a butcher knife and
stabs whoever's closest to him but also
more importantly than that michael myers
doesn't exist
but it's like it's like 100
with him on that like it's so dumb oh
it's so stupid you people out there
you're so dumb
like you know what michael myers is
walking by
west hollywood okay because he just
happens to be he's going to kill
everybody yeah i don't care you think
he's going to be like oh no not not that
you know i can only i can only kill
straight white but imagine being upset
imagine being upset about that oh i know
like you all don't have real problems in
your life
god you are just like that's your fight
for that that's the fight yeah
oh we got an urban meyer
grind sexy ass here that's funny okay oh
man see i like this costume yeah
why do you like this one that's what i'm
saying because you're not gonna see it
because he made it at home he made it
himself this is like
all he did was wear his [ __ ] ohio
state pull over and then yeah he's
trying to make a thing about he's a poor
person it means you can't buy that at
halloween market or you have to make
that halloween market
what's called halloween
where'd you get yours
target
it's a halloween market
don't don't shame it dude don't shame it
what do you get at the halloween market
halloween costumes though
man costume shots
parties no
halloween what spare halloween yes but
my bad
i like that the halloween market they
should call it you go get pumpkins
candy
the monopoly is over spirit uh
this guy he's uh
hasbala
at the ufc
hello dana i come to ufc
you know he's talking about the kid he i
don't know what he's talking about he's
no idea
what's going on with this kid i think
he's trying to stand in he has a
condition where he's actually he's 19 or
18 years old but he's literally this big
let me see
no but then they and that guy's a
monster that's what the little guy's 18
the little guy is 18. but he's huge he
has like that's a good baby boy no he's
18. no man
that's a kid i'd love to see you
wrestling
yeah he's not he's 19. but then he got
like that fake fight he got in that fake
fight too which was clearly staged after
the ufc yeah
well so that kid fights he trails one of
the biggest social media stars in russia
because he started hanging out with
khabib and
everybody thought he was dude he's a
monster i bet grappling he's a monster
he has some people i think so those
russians
this is him trying to fight another
little little dude
how much does he weigh
17 pounds i don't know i think it's
akbar oh my goodness oh [ __ ] he kicked
him
but that's like a little but the other
one's actually a little kid no also 19.
so those are two 19 year olds oh that's
some chernobyl [ __ ]
you take it easy too yeah
so i guess king it yeah so good job i
don't want him fighting yeah no i don't
want to get a regular-sized
visit betterhelp.com kats and see if
online therapy is for you and people you
care about
ufc 268 is here and draftking sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
ufc has a heavyweight offer for this
weekend's fight with a special odds
boost
for all of our listeners if you do not
have a problem with gambling then get
into it for fighters this week my picks
are michael chandler rose nama uranus
and kamaru usman the hot stepper that
dude will step on your feet for
40 minutes
just head to the app now and find
brennan shaw's picks under the odds
boost tab doesn't matter if you're a new
or existing customer bet on it get your
boosted odds and ride along with me all
new users download the top-rated
draftking sportsbook app now and use my
promo code k-a-t-s when you sign up
bet on my parlay of fighters to win
saturday night for ufc 268. i'm picking
dust and pourier to win every single
fight even the female ones and take
advantage of my special odds boost
that's promo code k-a-t-s only at
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of ufc must be 21
or older n g p a i n m i or v a only
those are states restrictions aptly
apply do you see draftkings.com
sportsbook for detail
gambling problem called 100 gambler or
in virginia 888 532 3500.
another debate club for us all right
what's going on boys
brendan theo stevie eric
my name is jared i'm from oklahoma i've
got a little debate club for you all
right monday night football if you're
watching that regular old boring espn
broadcast you switching over to [ __ ] is
boring cass with the eli and peyton
i personally like the manning cast
those two awkward [ __ ] somehow
make me laugh and uh bring some good
insight so let me know which one you
choose i mean all the mannings are doing
is basically a fight campaign for the
nfl nfl saw the success fight campaign
and said you know what let's do it with
the paint and bro bros i guess it's more
entertaining but the monday night
football it's just these old dudes now
it's not very entertaining well because
it you know they are awkward but peyton
manning is funny they're funny
eli's funny too yeah when they when they
when they lose they looser now yeah at
first it was like awkward super like
they have that show that peyton does
where like on the road he recaps know
the game because kobe bryant was doing
one talking about details details
the kobe bryant one was
so bad like he was so boring you know
you know that's how those guys are like
daniel cormier but it's like when you
get down to those details oh unless
you're a hardcore like right right he's
just so boring for me as a fight i was
watching dc
he would be like looking at a play and
he'd be breaking down the play and just
the way he was saying it it was nothing
exciting about it it just was like this
boring like monotone yeah yeah it's a
deep dive so how are you supposed to be
opposed to that well i don't know
that's what that's for though i think
it's just hard but peyton manning was a
little better about it yeah like peyton
manning like peyton manning because he's
just he was just a more like dc was
better than both of them yeah yeah yeah
this is a little highlight from last
week when they had marshawn lynch on oh
he cusses right and drinks yeah yeah he
i don't have the part where he costs but
he did get in trouble and peyton had to
apologize about him swearing even though
i swear to god last night payton dropped
an f-bomb but yeah this is
i i um you know i was watching your
interview with peyton on his peyton
places and i learned that before games
you had a pregame ritual where you do a
shot and a half of hennessy
before the game did you uh did you do
anything to you know get warmed up
tonight
i will see you see because i ain't
playing so i had a
i had a three shot minimum today
i'm feeling real good and i so so i took
one for me
i took one for big breath and i got one
for little breath so i made sure i was
perfect honored yeah they're really
entertaining
the funniest was peyton manning his he
has you know his kids are ballers like
their nephews like the number one
recruit in the nation really everybody
alabama every ohio state everybody's
coming after him he's a super baller but
peyton has a son who i think he's like
10 or 11 but he's you know obviously
it's his dad so it's his dad he's even
though his dad's one of the greatest
ever do it he's like whatever so his
son's playing this league and you can
put whatever name you want on the back
and peyton had jared allen on uh or not
jared allen uh allen for uh
he's a quarterback for the bills oh
right right he's like man
yeah josh down he's like should i feel
some type of way he can put any name on
his jersey and he goes i'm his dad his
grandpa's [ __ ] you know yeah archie
manning like they're all heisman super
bowl winners look at the name on his
jersey and it's uh josh allen right he's
like what kind of [ __ ] is this he's like
should i be upset as a dad maybe yeah
maybe i mean there's
isn't it crazy that they have four super
bowls
and and and and what and three mvp super
mvp wow i don't watch football i can't
really comment like you guys are into
football yeah yeah okay so chief suck
just know that i think we'll bring in
our guest now he's here right now yeah
will we recognize him uh some people
will you're a fan of the show you will
um so i don't know who he is
there's a there's a little music video
to go along with it as well here we
go okay
[Music]
[Music]
boys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you guys keep asking all the time are
you guys
oh
before soundcheck we went to say hi to
you guys you guys had a show right yeah
and it was you chin and then it was by
the uh out we went to you had a merch
all set up yeah it was cool and then you
left before you performed yeah oh wow oh
yeah
but yeah nick said you guys needed a new
theme song there's a new crew that's
awesome
pretty official nikki yeah
this is the team this is the squad
so how was the show how was that
was the show good like like was it it
was a good turnout there's some people
in there that one was decent that was
probably kind of the worst yeah the
worst one yeah
cause we went from like 391 tickets for
our first one yeah and we're just like
what the hell how why is there that many
people coming out who's in brown's
hometown yeah yeah that first one austin
yeah yeah what are your thoughts you're
also competing with a comedy festival
that's true there's a lot of stuff you
can be with yeah but it was awesome it
was a good experience
do you guys like the town you guys liked
it there yeah dude it's fun it was my
first time in austin yeah do you have
any in the schedule any dates not yet we
want to do last year we're trying to l.a
yeah
for sure there's so many places in l.a
right
what's that one over on um
people do a lot it's on santa monica
boulevard not viper room right no not
the viper okay it's not wait is it on no
it's on santa monica boulevard so it's
past like
all of the the gay club yeah it's going
towards beverly and there's that one oh
troubadour trooper troubadour
do you guys need a booking agent how do
how do you get gigs like how does that
work brows did it i've just been in his
people
now you could just browse a hustler yeah
but uh we did uh what's the one in
arizona the rebel lounge rebel lounge
that was awesome too chappelle chapel
came out
chappelle can help you guys out too
because yeah you know he tours yeah yeah
yeah so you're just doing it on your own
yeah oh well that's the best way until
it gets too overwhelming right like when
you need somebody to manage it but at
this point right now if you could do it
on your own do it on your own you don't
want somebody coming in being like well
we're going to take this amount of money
now
yeah you know what i mean yeah yeah you
don't need them as long as you're
looking
yeah uh a little later we have another
song a dedicated to our boy george not
boy george our boy
and he that he wrote george would be out
in dallas for now special table shout
out to george yeah i see george coming
special
for him how's he doing yeah he's good
that's good he's losing weight man still
still keto yeah still losing weight
what's up theo what's up brandon eric
speeby uh nick um thigh gap or whatever
that guy's name is i got a king or a
singer
adult kickball
i know theo used to play softball for
like a hmong bakery
um so i'm assuming he's into that but uh
how about kickball so king or sing it
about kickball leagues of course
listen a kickball's fun it's a blast but
as far as
organizing every thursday or some [ __ ]
has grown mad i'm out i'm not bashing
jerseys and [ __ ] i'll show up and
whatever the [ __ ] i want so you rather
sit around with your boys and talk about
a game instead of actually playing a
game i gotta go every thursday yeah i
can't make that commitment especially
for you especially for kickball because
you're too busy at food trucks and like
yeah
yeah
you're doing yeah you need some you need
some off time too yeah do some fun stuff
just every thursday though no one get in
the playoffs everyone getting all
serious taxing group taxing and [ __ ]
coming up with game plans well you know
i just people like to relive their glory
years and their glory years for most
people
it's like elementary in high school god
damn you know so that's why you have
like
a flag football league oh tetherball
tetherball tetherball
that was the sport for you my man
cut it out tetherball
so i think they do have like that
yeah
was in a softball league in nashville
but then he went against the all
japanese team got their ass what i
thought they were teammates were they i
thought he was against them and then
they got their ass with me quit
it's it's blurry i don't even know if
the team was real
i don't know
i don't know if he knows how to play
softball i'm all for some kickball you
know remember
you used to go like you know uh slowly
rollies you know you guys remember that
you would tell people how to pitch it to
you
baby bouncies give me some baby berries
crazy kickball we can run to first base
or third base you decide crazy
crazy cake ball dog that sounds like
some prison stuff you ever played you
ever played butt ball okay
i don't know i want to know about that
what is that
it was right up your alley
stevie heard butt and he was like what
did you say okay what does [ __ ] football
where uh you gotta hit the ball against
the wall and if someone gets the ball
and hits it before you touch it you
gotta stand there they throw the ball as
they can as your ass
okay
yeah dude i'm done no
let's do it man
we'll do all the activities huh guys
real day i like it yeah
the olympics yeah olympics with
tetherball football kickball all that
flag football flag football dude
what do you guys think i'm down
that's good content dude it just hurt my
knee thinking about that
no i'm just saying that
already
that's gonna be a lot of work for
christian and kyle but i'm down
yeah
yeah no we'll just find a courtyard or
something no a courtyard i do i don't
think we do all in one day like one week
might be kickball right basketball one
week's track and field you could do a
butt ball in here because it's big
enough you can do bubbles
yeah i'm still a little lost on but
get jerseys yeah stuff that'd be cool
yeah it's not like brendan went to juvie
you know what i mean
you sound like we grew up bro you sound
like juventus
crazy
me and nick play basketball one time
after the show and he was really good
we played a couple times yeah we gotta
get it again yeah you're good yeah i
don't say it popping
he's in the house yeah
he's definitely better than me he was
surprised that i was pretty good you're
good we were playing eighth graders
though and like
did you beat him though i don't think so
he's gonna hate me saying you know who's
the worst basketball player i've ever
seen in my life theo
no theo's not bad chappelle
no
bro really the worst
basketball player you've ever seen in
your life but he's got hops right no
really nothing was good nothing was he
didn't have a jumper he quit we were
playing 20 when he just quit playing at
13. yeah he was like not even 13. he
scored six he's like i'm out oh man
not shocked to be honest yeah he's just
too tight
he's just he's a big body yeah i don't
know yeah maybe you know you know i
guess you know when you're playing
basketball i was like i'll take your
belt first you know like you know you
don't
yeah
michael from the office over here
you know what i'm saying though guys you
know what i'm saying he's like first
pick who's tall and black got you
that's what i did
i know the line i put in there was
stevie weebe used to wrestle down in
paul way and now he only wrestles boys
in the hallway
he didn't hear that
[Music]
i'm a hubby driving home from your board
chrissy d's show in durham north
carolina
and
we have a king understand it for you
showering with the spouse
driving holding her hand strictly
business just showering together
none of that most the time
none of that stuff
just catching up catching up on your day
chatting about work
showering
no titties all soaked up
no distractions no phones just
showering together just because
so yeah they need like if you have a
double head right if you have like a
rain shower if you have like two spouts
yeah
but if they got just like the one and
it's just coming down or that that don't
sound like no dude my back blocks all
the water yeah it might grow like i'm
freezing like [ __ ] you get me the soap
my girl can't stand and i like me i like
it she hates it you guys shower with
your ladies yeah we have but it's not
like you don't like it and then also i
piss in the shower i'll piss my hair
she don't like that
oh you guys had sex in the shower
i like sex and water yeah i can't feel
it all right yeah
i can't feel it no i can't feel it i
agree it's overrated yeah i don't know
well that's only in the movies and then
and there's no real penetration going on
yeah you know it's not real sweet
uh so we're stinging it yeah we're
staying harvesting hard stinks
they should have shown us a picture of
their shower yeah or they've been in the
shower oh no bath is different a ba a
bath is a different store once again
dude baths what are you seven i did bath
make no sense you sit in the water it's
dirty water so you're just bathing no
bubble baths
no do you first of all you clean off
first if you want to shower first if
you're really dirty you rich rich dog
you rich rich when i go to a nice hotel
you take a bath oh i bring bath bombs
unreal
thanks for your honesty i want that
fizzle around me man i get bored man
yeah i have my ipad and i'm watching
movies and stuff they get a hot tub
really i mean you can't just get a hot
tub yeah we ain't rich rich in our star
wars money
he got star wars on it
yeah i'm [ __ ] elon musk yeah man
i don't like hanging out back in
bathtubs the water's warm i gotta jack
off you feel me i just don't like being
naked you see it's all right i wouldn't
want those
rules over here yeah i grew up rough
here i went one of those float tanks
before you're just chilling that warm
water it's all dark i'm like i'm gonna
jack up oh yeah well that's no
float tank deeper d what is it
sink in there uh i did and then out
you're in there for [ __ ] two hours
bro two hours yeah i was in there
forever the water's all warm i'm butt
naked is it is it black in there brendan
had nothing
brian was the chamber next to me and
we're in san francisco hey dog tusman
italians why don't you get up and get
the though you have a raging boner hand
me the towel
do you actually go to a different
dimension when you i mean rogan swears
by it you could go to a different
direction listen to rogan on that not me
[Music]
all right this guy's got a king at her
sting is this justin gaichy
i see it for sure what's up theo brendan
eric stevie
i'm hunter from auburn alabama
and i've been riding around listening to
jesse ventura not shut the [ __ ] up about
the rolling stones for the past 45
minutes
and it got me thinking
who are the top three celebrity
or public figures you'd love to beat the
[ __ ] out of
so as you can guess top of my list is
the conspiracy king himself
second
joy behar
i mean that's a given
third is lee corso
and all three of those are up there at
the age
i mean but it is what it is
um so yeah three public or celebrity
figures you'd love to beat the [ __ ] out
of gang gang buzz buzz this is easy
newsome number one gavin newsom i would
beat the piss out of and then fouchy i'd
slap him around i know he's older i just
slap him up rough him up yeah shake him
yeah shake him what are you doing
with
put a mask on
this is theo talking to ventura yeah uh
theo had jesse on and he did not enjoy
the interview first we should actually
just watch his wait theo didn't enjoy it
or jesse didn't
jesse enjoyed it theo did not enjoy it
oh wow whoa just listen to i'll let you
know too if you don't like something
listen to this intro okay
guest um
jeepers
you know i've never had an interview
where it was not a conversation really
so i think it's you know
and i'm saying this now because i i it
was hard to get a word in um did this
come out i am thankful for this man's
time but i was happy when it ended
and then if you just
keep going boy he looks crazy
he does look good that's jessie
commando [ __ ] keeper all of a sudden
folks
at any moment you can click around and
it's him going off and then theo trying
to get a word in and just getting
completely let me see
throngs that was the term they used it's
like you sliding in the ring with a
chair dude well yeah it was like i went
out oh he's not playing as a getting
back to your original question third
party
that's what uh you they all that's what
you've got to tap into to beat them
right you're not going to beat their
bases right you've got to get and but
most people are independent they
shouldn't set up you know what you push
me right now
i think it's just this place
our country is being covered and stopped
from doing anything by those 50 people
in the senate the 50 republicans
right
i don't know
60 votes or whatever
what do you mean you don't know you bad
stuff good good
yeah it uh oh dude i feel like theo's
gonna look like that in 30 years
i heard it yeah
he's like 12 years away
his hair starts leaving like that
eric stevie any celebrities you want to
beat up i can't i'm not off top i can't
think of anything yeah bobby lee there's
there's nobody like in the spotlight
that i'd want to be there yeah
oh we just don't want to say
you said the best one knew some news was
like just annoying in the room with you
kind of as a celebrity
yeah kind of he's pretty i mean pretty
popular right yeah speaking of bobby i
actually forgot this from our costumes
earlier this couple oh
what the hell that's pretty good
and their their actual names are bobby
and kaylee oh wow oh well that makes
sense that's insane
this guy's gotta can't understand it for
us he's looking for some life advice
waguan
that means what's up in jamaican i got a
king of the stingers for you guys
theo brennan
eric stevie weavey
so
can't understand it
relocating
i'm from new
york and now i'm in groton connecticut
some city no one ever heard of yes
what do you think about leaving all
your friends family i think you're
regretting it
from denver to l.a it's the best thing
ever happened here right
is it worth it to you or do you have a
long-term plan yes
like if it's short-term then no it's not
worth it because you're already
regretting it but if the thing is like
if i take this job in two years i'll be
able to do a b or c yeah then yeah then
you do it you know what i mean and you
just gotta know it's like uncomfortable
for a little bit when you get there you
know there's like a month where it sucks
you don't know anyone where you regret
your decisions it sounds like that's
what he's gone no but he obviously
what was the reason why he moved in the
first place like was he forced out or
did he make some choice because of work
or whatever it is so or better like it's
just a sometimes just a stopping point
for you to get to your end yeah but
don't make a lateral move you know you
know what i mean so connecticut's so
stingy
well i mean i don't think that's a king
yeah i mean i i moved here
yeah yeah uh brows is another good
person to ask he did it yeah yeah pretty
recently yeah okay well yeah i came from
ohio and i think i'm into the valley
right when i got out here and it was
weird i was like where the [ __ ] am i at
where are we at in the valley and like
northridge okay and
um then i got to the west side but it's
just weird because i did that to florida
too i moved to florida when i was
younger part of florida like fort
lauderdale okay and uh yeah i think it's
just weird for like two weeks until you
get like oriented right it depends what
you're go like if you know where you're
going yeah you have a plan i went for
rehab so it wasn't really
planned there's a plan
yeah but chin you relocated right from
texas to here korea texas in here
and i was willing to drop everything
here to go to texas with you if we were
going to move the show right i mean what
yeah when you would have gotten that
first happening
i said hey you're going to do that i
went out to austin looked at houses
looked at almost pulled the trigger on
two houses yeah
i text jen the group i was like hey
who's down to go i'm i'm looking at
houses right now chin was like say less
loyalty
you better believe it yeah
all right so we got uh the second song
from browse that i teased about george
yeah shout out to george he said he was
a fan of the music and stuff and i've
been watching his hustle and figured man
great [ __ ] kid yeah so he came to san
antonio at the time of his life i went
he's like man this is this best time my
life man blah blah i said well you ready
to do it again he's like when i text him
last week i said ready do it again he's
like shooting the special man you're my
lucky charm he's like are you seriously
you're coming man you'll be backstage
everything yeah that's cool he i think
he makes music too he's he sent me a
soundcloud link so
he wants to collab or something like
that
yeah we can do it
you know what now check this out so
we've had the wrestling battle now it's
time for the rap battle
battle like the voice we do the voice
and have chin and eric
how's it going
i want that as well if i go to bed it
would be nice and and we wake up yeah
that's more juvie stuff
yeah
i would not be able to be juvian him
because he'll be over there
stop crying like a [ __ ] and do it right
push that [ __ ]
out here
so we re gonna be r kelly
the video that had uh ja rules living it
up to the new original by little brows
so
this is him in san antonio too yeah yes
try to make it like a motivational
something to work out too and [ __ ]
[Music]
make plays break lanes push way break
chains go hard kick
[Music]
drop off the weight like
does george know this is happening
has he heard it no he's gonna be crunk
oh
[Music]
would stop he just yeah pushing forward
haters talk he ignore him the life guard
just a whip for when he grind he don't
cut corners wake up get it in it like
six in the morning and then grill him
like george may be no farming try to
slow him down
[Music]
you know it's gonna be a
thank you so much for coming out man i
love you guys before i close out tonight
i gotta bring this gentleman on stage
his name's george george
was 450 pounds and he said dude if i
lose 200 pounds i'll fly to la and i
will wrestle stevie i went dude you lose
200 [ __ ] pounds
i will fly to l.a i will fly you to my
show have you backstage and where george
comes from he doesn't see stuff like
this so the point of all this george is
there's so much more to this world man
you can [ __ ] do it brother i love you
man keep it up san antonio i love you
guys man i love this kid he's a great
guy
he's my lucky charm man and the song is
dope i work yeah
is
all right all right i would love that
though do you do any music stuff yes
comics bump us off and like give us this
run around
right yeah that's what i ask because i
do it old school like i loop break beats
and stuff right my mind's a little bit
like oh like like what you would do in
the 90s or something okay when the when
you didn't have computers so you're just
on like a little tape recorder yeah
basically
cassio all right that's all right dude
think about it
yeah that's all we got should we uh hear
that outro yeah
hey kids this thursday friday i'm in la
run my 30 minute special with the crew
david lucas chappelle lacy thursday
friday at the haha in los angeles then
next week thursday friday saturday
dallas shooting a special in dallas
texas addison improv we're going to add
shows there a few tickets left tickets
at fatk z.com love you guys hit it nick
little browns we love you man love you
guys you talented bastard vancouver
house of comedy
[Music]
[Applause]
theo said that he was on his way but ran
out of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at paw
way
night only finished boys in the hallway
this ain't the greatest show on earth
and what you call that eric griffin with
them he the nate
[Music]
just walked in and got it lit you can't
forget about brendan he still need
everything
thick they still got the bees in the
trap trapping
still the king and the sting so quit
asking if you know then you know it's a
cat's thing ball and chain hair swang
like the rat cane king
[Music]
[Applause]
theo said that he was on his way but ran
out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting
you